is the Hall of Famer from NFL networking
game day morning Marshall Faulk good
morning sir good morning come on ER
what's up Andrew nothing before we get
to Jared Goff the the Mike Neal and clay
matthews thing if you were in their
shoes Marshall what would you do would
you go in and talk to the league or
would you stand down um it's funny
because like the perception is if you're
clean go in and do what you're supposed
to do right let's but then but then bye
bye whoo by rule by collective
bargaining for the collective bargain
rule you don't have to but yet it's
being fed that if you don't think you're
not cooperating I mean every time you
get one of these situations it turns
into a litigation um you know I i really
don't know i'm not gonna lie to you i
really don't know what or rich which
stands all it take on this and rub i've
i've been asked several times by
different people and I just I can't
figure it out well the inclination the
natural inclination is to clear your
name but when there are bigger forces at
play with the union wants a bigger fight
then you just maybe become a pawn and
you have to sit back and let the Union
fight the league and then people say
well you know go clear your name well
then if I'm suspended and how do I
handle it how do I look at my teammates
what if I can't get out there on the
field for you know you know the first
couple of games I don't know but I do
know this I do know we have a game
Saturday it's the Rams it's the Chiefs
and we're going to see more Jared Goff
than we did see against the cowboys in
the opener do you think that Marshall
width say a great performance this week
and maybe an equally good performance
next week that he could legitimately win
the starting job or is it case keenum
regardless week one I think it's I think
if case we go
us because you can't you can't go
backwards and I believe Jeff and unless
I think that collectively on day
understand it doesn't matter how well he
plays there's not a I shouldn't say that
it doesn't matter how well he plays he
has to play exceptionally well or or let
me say this because i was with peyton
manning his work a year he has to be
able to have the resolve that if things
don't go well it doesn't respect his
confidence any understands that it's a
process if he if that can happen then
you can play if they don't see his
abilities to handle those two things
then with all those of how well he plays
you you have to you have to sit him and
and like case go out there and then
gradually bring him along and I tell him
in what week and I think it's determined
on how well he plays what week you bring
him in but he can lift a team but if you
start him and it doesn't go well and you
have to pull him then it could hurt the
team and I think the important thing is
I and we have to think about this just
just coaching in the last year of this
continent it's not like it's not like it
was what Peyton Manning I mean we can't
go three and 13 so Jarrett can learn
when you with Peyton you knew right i
mean you knew when you were in the
huddle with him when you were in
practice that he had it immediately
right right do right by you you've been
too early though you've been to irvine
have you seen that with goth yet yeah
you know what it's a it's that same
ownership of of the huddle it's the
command you watch the people around him
and I don't want to take anything away
from case I think cases done a great job
but the minute the minute the miniature
locks in the huddle there's just like a
little perk and guy's guy
men we as men we know alpha males we
know the guys when it when they step in
the huddle when they walk into the
locker room and I believe jared has
handled himself accordingly it's going
to come down to experience and how well
can he learn from his mistakes because
he's walking into a situation
unfortunately that that can destroy a
lot of other quarterbacks it has a short
a lot other quarterback which is this
team is ready to win now they have to
win now and they get to division games
right out of the gate as well with San
Francisco and Seattle that at home which
we have to factor this is Hall of Famer
Marshall Faulk joining us on the Dan
Patrick show I'm Andrew siciliano
sitting in for damn I've kind of lost
track with with all of us going
everywhere for for training camp were
you in denver yet have you been there no
no i haven't been to dim blurring
judging from a formative editor okay
judging from afar you think Trevor
Simeon gets that job it's that it's
tough to say but it's looking it's
looking like that's the case I don't
know I don't know how comfortable they
are with it but I think they're going to
take the same approach that I think I
think Sanchez it's going to get to start
and it'll be a short leash for him short
leash I think that's the case for him I
guess the question is can you change who
you are after I think Sanchez is in his
eighth or ninth year now and Mark is and
I think we saw it in the first preseason
game you get a touchdown to get a pic
and that's generally what his numbers
have been he's a touchdown for every pic
and a pic for every touch to put the
right coach and I believe you can you
can play different and I think and I
used to always tell people about Alex
Smith the process that he went through
in four years I'm in five years 75
different offensive coordinators how
tough that is he gets an eerie easing
he's in Kansas II and and now
alex is helping helping the team when
he's the reason they're winning games
he's not the reason that they're losing
games nor any manage game Alex Smith is
a viable quarterback in this league and
and I think that what the light kochi
multi has can lead that but in reality
when you put him let's say in situations
and it's sink or swim um BTW tim is to
see you know like the that Follies play
the black fumble 2000 yeah and that one
lives in infamy it's gonna be replayed a
hundred times it was replayed I think
last week when he threw a pick in
Chicago he's never going to escape it
but this is you know Marshall there's
there's part of me that really wants him
to do well here because you know if you
compare it to a plane he's being put in
the perfect cockpit here right he has
the wide receivers he's got the backs
the line might be a little sketchy that
you know they got four new starters but
he's got the defense everything is set
up for him here like you part of me
wants to see him do well because I think
it's a great story if he does well this
is I'll be honest with you and Buddha
Buddha Liana's is this is it yeah he's
been on teams and you've looked around
and wondered okay what is it well you're
being put in a situation and and as
great as peyton manning was last year
you know I at times with team they carry
Payton when he came through at times for
this team they didn't need a whole lot
to the quarterback position in assay of
stats and putting up putting up points
so this is the best situation for mark
if you can't come into this situation
seems today take advantage of an
opportunity and become the starter of
this team you will be a backup for life
that's that's it real quick the headline
when Tom Brady comes back week five
marshall faulk to face the Browns is
what our Patriots for know and he just
takes the keys back or as the Tom Brady
comes back to save the day because Jimmy
Garoppolo couldn't hold down the fort
what what team will they be blame Debbie
week 5 would be Josh Gordon's return as
well against the Cleveland Browns well
on the bones on the Cleveland Browns
that's a benefit we're on to the big
umbrella developers only one is going to
pretend like nothing that's different
like Tom Brady will be taking he'll be
having its first start everything will
be different for everybody else to leave
and Bill Belichick calm Brady and the
rest of everybody within that building
is going to act like nothing happened
Tom wasn't missing for four weeks and
they won't answer any questions about
the suspension no they won't they get
the Cardinals on sunday night the the
SNF game with NBC to open then it's the
Dolphins the Texans the bills at home
and what worst-case scenario there too
into their probably three and one either
they go on the road and they face the
Browns and Tom Brady probably sorry
Browns fans scores scores 50 put up so
50 burger on them Marshall Faulk Hall of
Famer along with yours truly and Hall of
Famer Eric Dickerson in the booth NFL
network will join us in progress will be
on CBS 2 in la the Rams and the Chiefs
at the Coliseum more Jared Goff please
coming up on saturday thanks for getting
up early man i'll see you saturday no
problem looking forward to the ages yes
sir Marshall Faulk everybody the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience